hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
paradoxical indeed is ansible say
ineffable we could call it features of
the divine substance and the way that
Ansel is is gradually working into it in
the bottle of Jim is then it admits of a
plurality that isn't completely
plurality in the sense that we're used
to thinking of in terms of say for
example three distinct pieces of chalk
right here there is a distinguished
ability that goes on and yet there's
also a supreme unity later on Anselm is
going to imply that perhaps even our
notions of unity and what we think of it
in terms of unity of worldly beings
tuzhel slave hideg area way of talking
about this is not the right model to to
apply to to the divine and he's going to
talk about this ultimately in terms of
the unity of the father and the son he's
not actually using that language in
certain of the passages that were
referring to here but this that's all
implicit within it earlier in moto G and
29 he has asserted that the the
utterance of the word what we're going
to call a little bit later the
lacoochee oh or the variable is the same
as the divine substance or spirit which
is uttering the utterance which is
expressing the word right the logos
logos theology here the logos is the
same thing as what is uttering that and
we've seen that the the word can be
understood as the reason or wisdom or
knowledge of God now again in momo-chan
37 he is going to say we've been talking
about two different beings here this is
a big loud bass because it really is
only one supreme creating being one
creator and origin has as he says he
says since he is consubstantial with him
whose word he is he must be the supreme
essence but there's only one supreme
essence how do we know this well
remember back to the earlier arguments
that we've done videos about about why
the divine has to be one there can be
only one super substance let's call it
and he says this is supreme essence is
the only creator and the only origin of
all created days so he says whatever the
Supreme Spirit makes his word also makes
and in the same way so both of them are
creating and in a service pack neither
one is creating apart from the other he
says whatever the Supreme Spirit is with
respect to creation his word is also and
in the same way nevertheless the two of
them together are not so in more than
one way for there is not more than one
Supreme creating essence so this seems
is it alright we really have unity here
why are we talking about plurality well
because there's different aspects
perhaps going on but it's all really one
one thing Mona loggia 38 is going to
open this up a bit and this is not going
to be completely satisfying to those who
want to apply a kind of logic or model
for being drawn from worldly beings and
ants
concedes that from the start he says
this is something quite unusual that's
the understatement there in the case of
other things but something that seems to
happen in the case of the Supreme Spirit
and is were he's already talking and
dualistic terms there so for it's
certain that whatever they are in their
essence and whatever they are in respect
to creation is present in each of them
individually and in both them together
in such a way has to be complete in both
and yet not introduce any plurality into
the two of them so if we consider the
the create war the supreme assets the
divine substance or spirit and we
consider the word by which he it
whatever we want to call it creates
which means you know the knowledge of
things before they actually exist in
themselves as we've seen then we've got
each of them being individually the
totality of the divine now this seems to
raise the problems right because now it
seems like we've got two different
Divine's there and each one is somehow
the entirety of whatever it is to be
divine so handsome is going to try to
work his way through this and the
argument that he's going to make here
ultimately rests on this point that the
word cannot be his own word that what is
involved in being the word of something
is some sort of distinction so he goes
on and he says that when we have here he
says it is in a strange way quite clear
the one whose word exists can that be
his own word and the word cannot be the
one whose word he is thus in that which
signifies either what they are
substantially or what they are in with
respect to creation they keep an
individual unity at the same time there
is an
affable plurality ineffable means that
we cannot fathom it we cannot express it
it's ironically were talking about
expression here right we cannot
adequately comprehend it so it's
ineffable in need so Ansel wants to
explore the paradox here although
necessity compels that they be two
things there is no way to express what
they are two off are they two gods are
they to divide substances no because as
we've seen there's a video specifically
about this divine substance is substance
in a way different than other things
that we call substances in other
metaphysical accounts of substance for
example Aristotelian accounts also claim
missed accounts what we're calling
substance here can only be in the divine
substance can only be one and yet it has
to have a plurality in it so he says
even if they can be said to be 2 equals
right in relation to each other if it's
asked what the thing is of which these
relatives are said one will not be able
to answer on the plural as when two
lines are said to be equal or two human
beings are said to be similar so they're
not to equal spirits or two equal
creators or two of anything that
signifies either their essence or their
relationship to creation nor are they
two of anything that signifies the
relationship of one to the other they're
not two words or two images so he goes
on and he says it is established one
cannot express with the Supreme Spirit
as word or two of even though they must
be too because of their individual
properties so what are the individual
properties that he's going to talk about
a bit later he's going to introduce this
this discussion that ties in with
Christian theology of fatherhood and
sonship of beginning and begot of
creating but rather generation him he's
not saying that this is exactly the same
thing as we understand by fathers and
sons he says this is this is you know
we're using human language to try to
express what is actually happening here
there's a very interesting discussion
about you know why paternal language
rather than maternal language is more
appropriate which we can consider it at
another time ansel nationally by the way
is very open to using maternal language
but isn't this a bit of a side no and so
in 43 he says we should consider what is
common and what is what is a distinct to
both of these he talks about a marvelous
plurality as ineffable as it is
inevitable in the supreme unity so this
is very paradoxical and we can express
the paradox quite well in these two
statements early on in chapter 43 he
says here we go it is impossible for him
who baguettes the father to be the same
as he who has begotten the Sun and for
the parents to be the same the parent to
be the same as the offspring right in
order to further to be beginning and
being begotten there has to be a
distinction because otherwise you don't
have heck's going on there's a relation
happening there and so there has to be a
plurality he goes on though and he says
nevertheless it's necessary that he who
begins be the same as he who has
begotten and that the parent be the same
as the offspring so much so that it is
impossible for the beginner to be other
than what the begotten is and for the
father to the other than what the Sun is
so what we've got here are not only two
seemingly contradictory propositions but
both of them seem to be necessarily the
case given the previous argumentation so
now this is not just a contradiction
this is like a super contradiction and
for in some it is a paradox that he's
going to try to tease out there's a
couple possibilities at
well you could say lot of paradox
contradiction throw it all up all this
is nonsense that's one thing you could
try to you know find some way to
reconcile them in a way that would make
you know entire sentence for the
rational mind sort of take all the teeth
out of the paradox so to speak Anselm
doesn't do that he's willing to still
recognize the limits of our
understanding of this at the same time
he's continuing to explore so he says
look the father is one thing the Sun is
another so much so that it is obvious
that they are too yes that which they
both are is so much one of the same
thing that it's completely obscure what
they are two up CM returning to this
point well what are the two things up or
two examples of there isn't anything
like that that we could we can say so he
says I see that I have spoken of two
things and yet that which is both father
and son is so much one of the same thing
I do not understand what two things that
I've spoken of although the father
individually is completely the Supreme
Spirit and son individually is the
Supreme Spirit we see this point made
again right nevertheless the father
spirit and son spirit is so much one of
the same that the Father the Son adapt
to spirits but one spirit so he says
just as the individual distinguishing
characteristics of each do not admit a
plurality so what is common to both
keeps its individual unity even the
Whipple arms holding two both it says
there are not two fathers or two sons
but one father and one son their
individual distinguishing
characteristics belong to them
individually so he says in virtue of
their relations they are opposed in such
a way that neither takes on the
distinguishing characteristic of the
other that means the father is the
father of the son and is not a son of
the Sun right the Sun is the son or the
word or the expression of the Father and
is not a father of something else in
turn or a father of the father they
retain the
as he calls of individual distinguishing
characteristics in their relations with
each other so it says in virtue of their
nature however they are harmonious in
such a way that each always has the
essence of the other handsome was
willing to allow the paradox to remain
in place to explore its intelligibility
to the extent that he thinks as possible
and then to continue on from that basis
and that is what he is doing so we do
have a unity of the father and the son I
should have also put unity and
distinction of the Father the Son
because they both go along at the same
time they're both the divine substance
they are not radically different from
each other in that respect they are not
two separate gods or divine substances
but they are distinguishable and this
does play a very important role in an
Psalms philosophical theology here in
the Mona loggia